hi today we're gonna see how document AI
can help unlock insights from documents
with machine learning data is crucial in
helping businesses make smart decisions
but today much of that valuable
information is dark data stored in
formats that are difficult to analyze as
Henry informs PDFs images and emails
companies in all industries and sizes
from financial institutions to media
companies to medical organizations face
this challenge
that's where document AI Google cloud
solution for understanding documents
like forms IDs and invoices can help
here's an example of what a solution
built with document AI might look like
Acme a fictional dental insurance
company processes thousands of claims
each week previously when they received
a form from a dentist's office or a
patient an acme employee would manually
enter all of the claim information into
a database this was tedious
time-consuming and lengthened a claims
processing time thanks to document AI
Acme has automated the process and
reduced the average time to close a
claim now when a new claim is received
the form is uploaded to the Acme dental
claim portal next the document AI API
analyzes the claim and extracts data
from its fields like patient information
procedure details and dentist
authorization after data is extracted
from the claim the Acme dental claim
portal automatically stores it in a
bigquery database Acme can easily search
browse and analyze claim data allowing
them to make better business decisions
so how did Acme do it when a claim is
uploaded it's sent through the document
AI API this API uses a specialized model
to understand form fields tables and
checkboxes once data is extracted from
the application it's stored in bigquery
Google clouds data warehouse where it
can be queried allowing Acme to service
insights through their portal now acne
employees can store claims in a database
flag anomalies and make better business
decisions faster without the burden of
manual data input to learn more about
how document AI can help you gain
insights from your documents check out
the documentation cloud Google com and
thanks for watching
[Music]